[Music]
hey guys Courtney says no here I am with
the Creator
Maura bracha kill such an honor right
now because she is a trailblazer in
creating TV and it just dates back what
20 years now Maura yes at first you like
you want to hide from that number but
I'm very proud of that number yes a
little over 20 actually and now you have
your new show love is out on June 19th
on own you guys I've had the honor of
seeing four episodes so far and you will
be hooked like me when you see this you
can add over some menu thank you and
liquor
we're finally getting to you and your
husband this power couple in Hollywood
you guys are finally coming together and
sharing your own story I mean we're
touching on a lot of things in love is
but one thing that I instantly grab to
is the fact that you guys are retelling
your love stories so you've probably
have to sit down and have some tough
conversations talking about past exes
how is how hard has that been working
together we've already talked about past
exes
okay the biggest conversation we had to
say is do you want it's inspired by yes
and you can still have some protection
but you are saying this is a lot of our
story that we're sharing and even if I
say no that actually I manipulated that
people gonna believe what they want to
believe
yeah I'm not you know and I think
sharing the story is again another brave
act it's it's just another brave act
that becomes less about you and more
about shared experience that I think a
lot of us can can just relax our
shoulders I mean we've all had that
situation when you hear you think you're
the only one going through something
good or bad mostly we obsess over the
bad stuff and we think we're the only
one making these dumb mistakes or and
then you hear someone else story and it
just gives you a little relief and I
think that's something that we've wanted
to share and also reflect on to
basically say and our biggest message is
that love is achievable if you design it
and define it for yourself
I really want Nuri and you see her to be
an ambassadors for the idea of designing
and defining it building being the
architects of your own life and that and
also that we all are deserving showing
black love is needed because I think you
know so much of our storytelling is
about survival about hardship suffering
overcoming and now that that makes for
good storytelling but we also understand
in mind that we are we are worth loving
and we are loving you're someone like I
said as a trailblazer I heard you say
that you were the Harriet Tubman yeah Oh
black TV and I feel that is so true
because you
an authentic experience for our stories
and black excellence I mean just tell me
about your journey and leading up to now
magical which is a theme that runs
through the show about love people have
asked how do you do it how do you do it
and it's it's it's magic sometimes you
don't know what you're doing you just
leave that's what I mean by the Harriet
Tubman is that I'm very proud of the
fact that a lot of actors a lot of
writers a lot of directors a lot of
costume designers a lot of department
heads rather their first have come
through come through by me having the
opportunity to be in that place to open
a door and so it's and and that's been
magical I think you're a unicorn in this
industry I really do because I love you
Courtney but you're a unicorn because so
many people find it hard to bring people
up with them and you're someone who's
done that from girlfriends being Mary
Jane and the list goes on with
everything that you've done co-creating
Black Lightning which is a success but
you have been someone who has been
inclusive since day one how hard was
that coming up did you have any barriers
was there a glass ceiling for you that
you broke through before we got to this
to where we are now oh yeah there's a
lot of fights yeah and I think you just
have to be willing to battle and battle
strategically and respectfully you know
I learned how to do that and I don't
always know where my fearlessness well
let me just say this
I was scared be real clear about that
but I did it anyway
yeah because I think it's funny when I
think about even the character of Marie
and love is I think sometimes people can
look at inspired by me could look at me
almost naively and maybe she is a little
naive but actually there's a bravery
there's a bravery to saying yeah I'm
gonna fall in love with you or I'm going
to accept you a man who doesn't have a
lot of means there's a lot of bravery
and going into the studio and saying no
Tracee Ellis Ross needs to wear her hair
natural here you and I are sitting here
our curls are big and out that was not
happening in the early 90s that was not
happening not to say that what was
happening was wrong it just was not
inclusive of what was real and just to
take that bite up and say no we're gonna
have her wear her natural hair yeah
remember the costume it was a costume
designer moment that she was just right
for the job it wasn't like I was just
fighting for people randomly I'm
fighting for what's best for the show
exactly and look what happened with
girlfriends in terms of the fashion
statement that it made I remember there
was some friends of mine who attorneys
and they were like Joan gave me
permission to be fly in the office I did
but she did and so those things those
fights that we had or I had I'm thankful
for them and sometimes I don't know who
that warrior he is but I keep leaping
anyway exactly and then even with love
is the fact that you left it open-ended
I love that because love is is fun story
so the show was titled something else
really and you know and it's funny
Oprah's giving she hasn't give she
hasn't given a lot of those but her
notes are so on point and I was in love
with this other title by the way it was
called documenting love documenting and
you probably can see why when you see
the show yes there's a and I was in love
with it and she's like hahaha
and so but we talked about it so I made
a list and she was my Nicholas and then
we were gonna get back together and go
over our live yeah and do you know we
both picked love is really but when you
have a moment like that it was again so
much magic around this project and when
we landed on and then just sort of let
it wash all over you it is so it is such
an amazing title I love it I'm inspired
by the title even that that blank is
very inspiring to me this is what love
looks like
I noticed Marie and yes yes yes here is
that inspired by your son's name yes
combined and it's so funny my oldest is
yes see my youngest is my seer and of
course you can put one person one
child's name over the other that's just
like horrible mommy 101 yeah and then
when I put it I put it together and then
found out what the meaning was I just
was like wow how in and truly the
essence of who Selim is you chose two
phenomenal actors to play you and Celine
tell me first I want to talk about Nuri
because I I assume that she probably
have a little bit of pressure playing
you loosely playing you I think she did
phenomenal what I do love there first of
all I prayed for them I prayed for them
and so that that and and God answered
immensely I was like thank you I mean
and to have these fresh faces but with
depth of talent I think will represents
just oh he's just it's just looking in
his eyes feeling his energy it's it's
very deep it's very layered
Michelle who I love she has a brightness
that I do believe is a bit of my essence
but it's complicated and layered as well
the only thing I've got nervous about
because Michelle had these long curly
tresses I mean long curly tresses I was
like I hope she read that stage
direction when we went to Nikko who cut
my hair back in 1996-97 and so Nikko cut
her hair and it's just been on this
journey the insomnia café we actually
met there we got to shoot there the
furniture store that's in the pilot that
was exactly the furniture store that was
exactly the same owner that's exactly
the corner of the furniture store that
but but that's my point I mean it could
still be there but even the the the
reality that someone would actually rent
it to you for filming and all that
Melrose that was exactly the spot in
which I saw him
even to have those moments the magic
around these moments and the magic of
finding Michelle and will and as
according to my kid it was like mom she
looked like you when your kids say it
maybe so
I like that that helps too it's a little
fun and I think we'll just look reminds
me so much of Celine his essence and his
looks I'm like okay business this is a
lot of fun
[Music]
[Applause]